Speaker 1: Okay. Let's go next to
John from Kentucky. Welcome, John.
Speaker 3: Hi there, buddy.
Speaker 1: Dear God.
John, you're coming through all modulated like
you're a robot. You're not a robot, are you?
Speaker 3: I am not. Can you hear me now?
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's better. You sounded like
C3PO or three CPO or whatever it is.
Speaker 3: Yeah. As a Star Wars, I can say
you were right the first time.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 3: Or a previous Star Wars fan, but
that's not what I'm calling about. Okay. So
I was keeping track of the Supreme Court stuff
over the last couple of weeks, just like everybody
else has. And, of course, the Dobbs decision
was heartbreaking. Yeah. See what happened
to, you know, actively creating half of our
population as second class citizens. That's
something that we all have to contend with over
the next year. But what the decision that really,
really caught my attention over the last couple
of days was the Kennedy decision. And while I
used to be a Christian and I can understand why
Christians initially believe that, you know, it's
innocuous, the football coach, he believes his
creator is going to protect him and so he should
pray over people. I can understand the Christian
perspective. Yeah, but what is important to me
is not as thoroughly the decision itself,
but the fact that because of the case
in his decision. Like by saying that the by saying
that the the coach was almost the same. The coach
was just quietly praying to himself in midfield at
any time that any other person he wasn't acting as
a representative. Right then Justice Sotomayor
posted a picture of him praying with the entire
team. He clearly acting as a representative, and
the football coach at that time was wondered like,
I have a conservative aunt who argues as
this facts versus alternative facts stuff.
It's just a little bit scary seeing that type of
argumentation coming from the Supreme Court now.
Speaker 1: Without a doubt, you're absolutely
right. It was not a quiet prayer. It was a
huge thing. The coach with multiple circles of
players around him and then media around them,
its implicitly coercive because
of the power dynamics. And John,
you're completely right in your assessment.
Speaker 3: Absolutely. Absolutely.
And just like Mark, I just want to say
congratulations on the baby, man. And yeah,
you have a wonderful rest of the day.
Speaker 1: All right. There we go.
There is John from Kentucky.